well it seems like just after i release  a video on the controversy of the nike  versus mischief the  satan shoes trademark case well the  party's just  up and settled so this case is really no  more as part of the settlement at least  the part that's public nike says that  mischief will recall the shoes and offer  a full reimbursement to anyone that  purchased the shoes and wants a refund  but other than that it doesn't seem that  the parties agreed to  any other terms so it doesn't seem like  mischief is going to have to pay nike  anything which of course  is a great result for mischief because  they got tons and tons of publicity  which is of course  what they wanted in the first place so  it doesn't look like we'll see nike or  mischief in the same court again but i  will see you  in court